[Music]
when you see her when you see him that
is generations manifested and woven into
the fabric of these games those 81
points that 958 those 23 Grand Slams is
our Alchemy our Essence is encrypted
into the moments that stand the test of
time to Glory the soul of Athletics lies
within her lies within him lies within
us
the beauty in the game is the beauty in
our name our Sisterhood our Brotherhood
Family Ties Black History Month is every
month the fits the nails the braids the
pros the chains the lingo was baked in
it's all dog around his mother we've
rebelled we've shined we've laughed and
we've danced our value cannot strictly
be tied to accolades because something
bigger was achieved
[Music]
we've gifted sports with identity spirit
and culture
voice has a purpose because you know all
along it's always been black
because all along it's always been black
because I'm alone it's always been black
sports history is Black History